hey youtubers is Charlie hail Hydra so
this week's agents of shield was a
direct continuation from the end of the
events from Winter Soldier of the movie
so it really is like the beginning of
the final arc on the show so what I'm
gonna do is I'll talk about how the show
in the movie are integrated you know
what the plot is it's working together
then I'll do my top five moments in my
review I'm also gonna talk about some of
the ramifications about some of the big
changes that happen during Winter
Soldier and how that's gonna affect
season two of agents of shield if it
does get renewed because there are some
big changes that happened also quick
heads up all those big changes that are
happening they also affect the plot of
what Captain America 3 is pluggin to be
so I'm gonna do a movie video for that
tomorrow morning be sure to subscribe to
get it
it's gonna be all about Secret Avengers
it'll be a lot of fun so first things
first let's talk about how Winter
Soldier of the movie integrates with
this episode careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the movie or if you haven't
seen this episode yet the timeline is
like this the Hydra Helicarrier strike
started right before this episode
started the end of Winter Soldier
you know whenever Captain America
destroys them happens just as they're
capturing agent Garrett and his men when
Victoria hand said the Captain America's
whereabouts are unknown that's about the
time he was at Nick Fury as brave with
Anthony Mackie Nick Fury still wants
everyone to think he's dead so Coulson
and Han still don't know that he
survived he's off trying to track down
more rogue Hydra agents Chris Evans and
Anthony Mackie are basically doing the
same thing only separately they're
tracking down the Winter Soldier and
more Hydra agents the movie and this
episode pretty much end at the same time
obviously the show has five more
episodes left in the season so we can
talk more about where things are headed
in my top five moments but here we go
number five Skye decodes the Hydra
message on the bus the message was sent
to all Hydra double agents just telling
them to seize control of shield that
went out while they were launching the
helicarrier's in the movie that was when
crossbones and Robert Redford basically
revealed who they were I love the
reaction of Coulson and the crew but
because I like everyone else in the
world saw the movie last week it wasn't
as big of a surprise for me as it was
for them I loved those lines though out
of the shadows and into the light time
to face the Hydra music which actually
makes me wonder what is the theme music
for Hydra is it like the Star Wars
Imperial March hmm number four may comes
clean about Tahiti before this there
were
to people I thought she could have been
reported to based on her allegiance
Robert Redford and Nick Fury
I'm actually pretty glad she turned out
to not be a double agent for Hydra how
cool is it though that she basically
inception their whole team into Coulson
said via Nick Fury like she gave fury
the idea for their names and fury
suggested them to Coulson and thus the
team was born I'm curious to see what
her relationship with him will be like
once the dust settles I am expecting
some sort of Hail Mary's save in the
finale so that Coulson will start
trusting me again but you know until
then she's gonna be an ally but not a
friend number three Victoria hands epic
Hydra faked out just one of the many
awesome fake outs in the episode when we
saw the end teaser last week that
revealed you know she was remote
piloting the plane I was pretty sure she
was not the clairvoyant
so when she gave them that Hydra speech
I was actually pretty surprised in the
comments Victoria had worked for hammer
but she is an outright evil like a Hydra
agent I was actually pretty relieved
whenever she took it all back and said
that they passed the test had she had
been an actual Hydra agent they probably
would have eventually had to kill her
off the show unless she was going to
become some new Big Bad and there really
wasn't anything I saw on the show that
led me to believe she was gonna become
some new big you know masters of evil
big bad number two Garrett is revealed
is the actual clairvoyant surprisingly
not the biggest reveal in the episode
Bill Paxton does such an amazing job of
playing sleazebag characters how could
we not have known that he would turn out
to be the sleazebag double agent for
Hydra to be fair he was not always Hydra
he said that he saw the wind blowing in
their direction and just switched sides
so when he and Coulson were training
together under Nick Fury he was still on
the good side in the comics Garrett's
character eventually becomes part of the
Avengers but before that he was a pretty
big douchebag so there's a lot going on
with this character I'll talk more about
that in a second though and my number
one WTF moment Ward is Hydra or is he
huge reveal Ward shoots Victoria hand
and the guards so we're supposed to
think he's either Hydra or just decided
to turn right there on the spot but wait
let's think about this for a second
personally I think that he's just
playing Garrett in order to uncover you
know who some of those other top-level
Hydra agents are like Ward is really a
double double agent you know he's still
a good guy what about those gunshots
though did he
kill Victoria hand we didn't see any
blood and remember Coulson told them to
use the night-night guns whenever they
first landed at shield headquarters we
never saw him switch guns so he was
probably still using the stun gun and it
only appeared he was using real bullets
I don't remember him ever telling agent
Garrett about the night-night gun
technology that was something that fits
developed on his own so it's not normal
shield tech thus I think that in a
couple more episodes we'll find out that
Ward is on a secret mission for Coulson
to find out who those other Hydra agents
are you know he's not really a bad guy
right now here are actually a couple
really big moments that I didn't want to
occlude my top five but I thought were
really cool nonetheless first off
Garrett gives agent Stillwell a big
shout-out for hiring a ton of Hydra
agents I guess he was a human resources
person then Garrett tries to recruit
Fitz to be hydras new Arnim Zola next
May calls out Ward for having a total
hard-on for sky and then sky and Ward's
you know let's have a drink moment
they're now officially the second
biggest ship on the show next to Coulson
in the cellist we're actually gonna meet
the cellist pretty soon she's gonna be
played by Amy Acker so it's gonna be
really cool but now it's your turn let
me know what was your favorite moment
was it all the fake outs was it finding
out that Garrett was the true
clairvoyant or was it the big Ward
reveal at the end overall I rated the
episode as a solid b-plus it did a good
job of incorporating this huge
convoluted movie plot from Winter
Soldier
that was a two-and-a-half-hour movie not
an easy job and it revealed all these
new layers and the existing characters I
love what they're doing with all the
relationships on the team you know not
just the sexual relationships but the
friendships too like Coulson and May I
fully expect all those broken trust
issues to be fixed by the end but the
Hydra cat-and-mouse chase is gonna be so
much fun to watch between now and then
there was also this really awesome
interview that Kevin Feige did and he
talked about talking to Joss Whedon
about the show and how it worked with
Winter Soldier they originally knew the
plot of Winter Soldier before they knew
about agents of shields plot and Joss
Whedon was forced to kind of work within
this idea of shield coming down so they
actually had to rewrite agents of shield
to work with Winter Soldier back to the
episode though they did have a couple
really nice callbacks to some earlier
moments especially the stuff that was in
the fridge one of my favorites was their
reference to gravitonium I keep
expecting graviton to bust out of the
fridge with all the chaos that's
happening right now
but overall the
get surprised was that Arnim Zola was
not the clairvoyant it was actually
Garrett a real person all along I was a
little disappointed because I really
liked the idea of AI being evil you know
give him what the plot of Avengers 2 is
going to be with Ultron the only other
thing in the episode that I didn't
really like was whenever they were
carding Garrett off and they had that
slow motion music montage I think I
would have liked it better if Triplett
had just you know gone up and tackled in
like the Hulk but real quick let's talk
about what all this shield crashing down
business says about season 2 of the show
it also kind of ties in with the plot of
what Captain America 3 is going to be -
so first off the show has not been
renewed yet even though every single
other show on ABC has gotten renewal or
cancellation notice they haven't said
anything about it but I think that's
only because they're trying to hide or
at least hold off and revealing what's
gonna happen during the season finale
it's all about the plot of Secret
Avengers the comic I'll be talking more
about it during my Captain America 3
bonus video tomorrow because it's all
about the destruction of shield and
Captain America putting his own separate
team together to go on covert missions
because I kind of think if she'll get to
season 2 that's what Coulson and his
team are gonna do they're just gonna go
on secret missions like I said I'll be
explaining all that stuff in the Captain
America bonus video tomorrow be sure to
subscribe to get it now let me know what
are your final thoughts in the episode
do you think it did a good job of kind
of holding up the pacing and the tone of
Captain America I actually almost
thought a week ago I feel like the
episode would have worked better if I'd
have seen the movie like right before
seeing the episode but it was still a
lot of fun and I'm really excited to see
where the show goes from here also don't
forget next week's episode is Patton
Oswalt so it's gonna be a lot of fun but
you can click here to get that bonus
Captain America 3 Secret Avengers video
I'll have the annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here to get my
other top choices for a Captain America
3 story so thank you so much for
watching hail Hydra I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you